- [Voiceover] We're told
to fill in the blanks
to complete the equation
that describes the diagram.
So let's think about
what's going on over here.
If we start at zero, and we
move one, two, three, four
spaces to the right of zero,
this arrow right over here
represents positive four.
We already see that right
over here in the equation.
Then from positive four,
from the tip of this arrow,
we then go one, two,
three, four, five, six
spaces to the left.
So what we just did here is we just added
a negative six to the positive four.
Positive four plus negative six.
Where does that put us?
Well we see it puts us one, two spaces
to the left of zero and
each of these spaces
in this diagram are one.
So two spaces to the left of zero
is going to be negative two.
This is fun. Let's keep
doing more examples.
Write an addition equation
or a subtraction equation,
your choice, so they're
giving us some choice,
to describe the diagram.
Alright, let's see what's going on here.
We're starting at zero
and we're going one, two,
three, four to the left.
So if we're going four to the left
or so we can say negative four, -4.
And then we're going
to go another one, two,
three, four, five, six, seven,
eight, nine to the left.
So we could write this as
negative four minus nine
is equal to.
And when you go four to the left
and then you go another nine to the left,
you end up 13 to the left of
zero which is negative 13.
Equals negative 13.
So this way I've written it
as a subtraction equation
I guess you could say.
Negative four minus nine,
is equal to negative 13.
Now another way I could have done it,
I could have said negative
four plus negative nine
is equal to negative thirteen as well.
Either of those would
have been legitimate.
Now I've written it as
an addition equation.
Let's keep going.
Fill in the blanks to
complete the equation
that describes the diagram.
So we're starting at zero, we go three
to the left of zero,
that's negative three.
Then we go another three
to the left of that.
So we're going to add
another negative three.
We're going to add another negative three
and that puts us six to the left of zero.
Well six to the left of
zero is negative six.
And we're done.